mehr sicherheit für unsere frauen und
töchter unterstützung für die afg bei
landtagswahlen und der bundestagswahl
2017 wer die großplakate finanziert hat
unklar die afb will nichts zu tun haben
mit der kampagne des vereins für
rechtsstaatlichkeit
wir haben mit diesem verein für
rechtsstaatlichkeit nie
zusammengearbeitet sondern die haben von
sich aus wahlkampf unterstützende
maßnahmen ergriffen und wir sagen wir
kommen da in ein cover verein wo man uns
den vorgemacht dass er illegale
parteienfinanzierung
seit jahren gibt es diesen verdacht die
spur führt nach andelfingen in die
schweiz hier sitzt die werbeagentur goal
ag die hinter dem verein für
rechtsstaatlichkeit steht die firma
verweigert bisher jede auskunft zu den
finanziers der plakatkampagne und zur
rolle der afg nachfrage versuch beim
firmenchef
seit vier jahren mit ihnen zu reden und
sie haben unsere als anfang ich
beantworte ich würde jetzt gerne in
fragen wie ihre zusammenarbeit mit der
ard bei ihrem plakat aktion ausgesehen
alexander segert ist im büro doch er
redet nicht fehlt lediglich unser team
beantwortet auch keine schriftlichen
fragen
segert ist chef der goal ag und experte
für kampagnen rechter parteien die pro
fd werbung kostete mutmaßlich millionen
geld von unbekannten spendern
jetzt konnten das recherche netzwerk
korrektiv der spiegel und frontal
hunderte seiten interner unterlagen
einsehen sie lägen nahe dass bei
plakatkampagnen doch eine verbindung
zwischen der schweizer goal ag und der
afg bestehen könnte es geht um
buchungsunterlagen des kölner plakat
vermag das ströher
ströme plakatierte die proa fd werbung
dem wert von rund drei millionen euro
das geht aus den internen unterlagen
hervor
ein beispiel eine pro afd kampagne zur
landtagswahl in nordrhein-westfalen
ein auftrag bei ströher umfasste
956 großplakate zum preis von
436.000 331 euro
agentur ist alexander segert goal ag als
direktkunden genannt die alternative für
deutschland
also dass die ströher die vereins
kampagnen der ard als direktkunden
zuordnet heißt er das leben der form
eine koordination gegeben haben muss
weil es ist nicht nachvollziehbar dass
ströer das ohne absprache mit der afg
gemacht hat und das führt dann im
nächsten schritt dazu dass man diese
wahl werbeaktivitäten des vereins
eigentlich der ard zu rechnen muss
ströher einer der größten plakat firmen
mit 300.000 plakatflächen die firma
teilt mit sie sei nicht berechtigt den
finanzierungsweg der auftragnehmer zu
überprüfen zitat
in bezug auf parteipolitische werbung
muss das unternehmen unterstellen dass
die rechtlichen vorgaben eingehalten
werden
noch ein beispiel plakate zur
bundestagswahl 2017 mein auftrag hat den
wert von 1,2 millionen euro für
2291 plakate agentur ist wieder die goal
ag als direktkunden genannt die
alternative für deutschland so die
unterlagen wir finden viele plakat
buchungen mit dem direktkunden afd
plakate von denen die partei behauptet
sie habe von den kampagnen zwischen 2016
und 2018 nichts gewusst es werden bei
der bundestagswahl 1 2 millionen euro
fast nrw-landtags 2 und eine halbe
million euro wenn jetzt alles zusammen
ziehen kommen wir auf drei millionen
euro bei den unterstützern plakaten und
wenn sich rausstellt dass die partei
davon tatsächlich wusste dann hätten wir
demnach drei millionen euro illegale
spenden wir zeigen der parteien
forscherin sowie schönberger unsere
recherchen
wir haben jetzt den nachweis dass ist
eine koordination der kampagne beim
außenwerber beim plakat hersteller gab
und wir haben sehr starke indizien dafür
dass die afd in einem gewissen umfang
hier eingebunden war das würde den
geldfluss zu einer illegalen
parteispende machen deswegen sollten
jetzt staatsanwaltschaft und
bundestagsverwaltung ermittlungen
aufnehmen
afg landesparteitag in stuttgart wir
konfrontieren die parteispitze mit
unseren recherchen nachfrage bei
bundestags spitzenkandidatin alice weidl
bleiben sie dabei dass sie oder auf die
funktionäre in keiner weise in die
koordinierung der plakatkampagne des
vereins zur erhaltung der
rechtsstaatlichkeit und boll ag
verwickelt waren aber natürlich nicht
natürlich
über anwälte lässt die afg mitteilen sie
habe weder mit der goal ag noch mit
einem externen verein bei einer kampagne
zusammen gearbeitet
zitat
die von ihnen behaupteten eintragungen
als direktkunden in bezug auf die von
ihm behauptete unterstützer kampagne
sind unserer mandantschaft nicht bekannt
und weiter heißt es eine
falsche zuordnung einer anderen
angeblichen kampagne zu unserer
mandantschaft liegt aber allein im
verantwortungsbereich des unternehmens
ströher
doch es gibt weitere hinweise dass die
afg mit der schweizer goal ag
kooperierte bei plakataktionen über die
firma ströer frauke petry damals
parteichefin erhält im januar 2017 eine
sms von einem afd mitarbeiter
ts ströher will dich dringend sprechen
geht um die koordination der edlen
spender aus dem süden
edle spender aus dem süden unterstützten
afg chef wollte der musste wegen einer
illegalen spende der schweizer goal ag
270.000 euro zahlen afg abgeordnete
guido reil musste 132000 euro zahlen
auch wegen werbung der go lucky und von
spitzenkandidatin alois seidl fordert
die bundestagsverwaltung knapp 400.000
euro strafe wegen spenden aus der
schweiz
die vermutung liegt erstmal nahe dass es
tatsächlich um ein geldgeber aus der
schweiz geht der das ganze auf diesen
umwegen versucht hat in die afg zu
schleusen das müssen jetzt
staatsanwaltschaft der
bundestagsverwaltung einzelnen klären
berlin die generalstaatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt der vorwurf falsche angaben in
rechenschaftsberichten der afd es gehe
auch um die unterstützung aus der
schweiz
es gibt seit frühjahr 2009 10 ein
ermittlungsverfahren den
bundesschatzmeister wegen dieses
sachverhalts bereits seit herbst 2008 10
haben wir diesen sachverhalt umfassend
geprüft und dieser prüfung ist auch
nicht abgeschlossen goal ag chef
alexander segert schweigt seit jahren
die afd dementiert jede zusammenarbeit
mit segert und rechnet mit einstellung
des ermittlungsverfahrens
parteichef leuten bestreitet jede
kenntnis von kampagnen bei ströer mit
der go lucky nur eine langjährige
bekanntschaft hat er zugegeben ich kenne
herrn segert und damit die hinweise
verdichten sich dass es da einfach auf
ganz vielen ebenen gespräche und
beziehungen und verbindungen gab
natürlich kann man in hinblick auf die
goal ag und herrn leuten sagen in
freundschaften wird über das
geschäftliche nicht geredet aber wenn es
um solche summen geht und eine direkte
beteiligung der freunde dann ist das
jedenfalls keine besonders plausible
geschichte
die internen unterlagen der firma ströer
belegen plakat buchungen mit wahl
aufrufen für die afd im wert von mehr
als drei millionen euro die
bundestagsverwaltung kann prüfen ob afd
funktionäre involviert waren
und da kann es sein dass die
bundestagsverwaltung dann nochmal
strafbescheide in zwei bis dreifacher
höhe des budgets dieser wahlwerbung
verschickt an die art plakat vermarkter
ströer hat nach unserer anfrage jetzt
mitgeteilt das unternehmen stockt ab
sofort jede parteipolitische werbung
[Musik]